in 1956 you and i graduated from
Carnegie Mellon University over the
years we've had a lot of conversations I
figured after 55 years I might know
something about you but every time we
talk I learned something more like
yesterday when you told me for the first
time the story about giving a lecture at
the Vatican and telling the Pope what he
should do with Galileo so this evening
I'm really looking forward to hearing
more stories about the steps on the path
to being in my kebab so we have to start
by rolling back let's roll back to
nineteen ninety-four I was a good year
that was a good year to be at fighting
about because n Feigenbaum in 1994 won
the ACM touring award which is the Nobel
Prize for computer science e1 that
jointly with rod Freddie maybe you
should read the citation here before I
do I got to say that already Arnold's
not telling the truth because I actually
met him in 1952 remember we were both
undergraduates we were both returned any
brothers and I knew him for our whole
undergraduate life and then we graduate
the ACM citation said this was
incidentally joint with Roger Eddie and
most of you in the audience no Raj Raj
was one of our students at Stanford I
consider him Stanford's greatest gift to
Carnegie Mellon and then he went to
Carnegie Mellon and the rest is history
but in 1994 he he and I both won the war
for I endure the design and construction
of large-scale artificial intelligence
systems demonstrating the practical
importance and potential commercial
impact of artificial intelligence
technology 3 what they're coming well
you told me once that you would have
written that some other way well let me
focus on a couple of other things that
that I was mentioned in the citation the
citation read literally it talks about
the design and construction of
large-scale artificial intelligence
systems that's a very engineering
sounding job well the motive of getting
in to that area was not an engineering
motive at all it was a scientific motive
it was a motive to extend the work of
the first generation of artificial
intelligence researchers that started
with actually with Newell and Simon at
Carnegie Mellon and went through about
19 from 1955 through 1965 to extend that
into the area of empirical induction
Newland Simon had been working on
problem solving methods for example
we'll talk later about heuristic search
or means-ends analysis the tasks that
they used to further this scientific
research were relatively simple tasks of
either theorem proving or puzzle solving
and in my view the larger
cognitive tasks that we do all the time
is the task of empirical induction
making sense of what one of the
Philosopher's called the bluing bloody
confusion of the world all the data
that's pouring in and we are constantly
making models building little theories
about our world and occasionally those
little theories are not so little at all
occasionally their big major scientific
theories so I wanted to explore that
whole space how what do you have to add
to what Newland Simon had to say and
other people in the first generation
what do you have to add to that to get
to really good empirical induction now
we did indeed make a major discovery
down that route and it's a it's a major
scientific discovery oh and it
conditioned the way that not only a I
people but also most computer scientists
viewed the world of constructing largent
interesting programs we were the the the
discovery is the one that originally I
called the knowledge is power hypothesis
and I borrowed knowledge is power from
Francis Bacon of course he used it in a
political context i was using it in a
technical context meaning that
intelligent programs behave at high
levels of intelligence that it's solving
complex problems to the extent that they
are very knowledgeable about their
universe their domain of discourse
knowledge about the task and that the as
a corollary of that the inference
processes that are used in making in
doing that problem-solving play a
relatively minor role now this is a very
very much counter to the theme of the
first generation of of AI science in
we'll talk about 1956 and the great work
at carnegie mellon which was then
Carnegie Tech incidentally we'll talk
about that in a moment but in 1958 one
of the cofounders of a I truly great
computer scientist one of my Stanford
colleagues John McCarthy gave a paper at
the first AI conference held in England
it was called the mechanization of
thought processes conference and his
paper was called programs with common
sense but the emphasis in the paper was
not about common sense it was about the
idea that one would use the entire
Armada of mathematical logic
particularly 20th century mathematical
logic to blast open a whole problem of
how to solve complicated things in the
world AI would be built out of those
formal systems let's move let's move
back from that a step back you refer to
it to kind of build a little foundation
under what you're talking about what was
the great Christmas breakthrough of 1955
1956 you called it a supernova yeah that
took place at Carnegie Tech yeah let me
let me get to that and decide once want
to finish this one thought that as we
were when I say we I mean myself and
Joshua later Berg at Stanford Nobel
prize-winning geneticist who
collaborated with me on this work and
one of my young research associates at
the time now famous computer science
professor bruce mccannon we were solving
problems in the mass spectrometry of
organic molecules now that's quite
different incidentally than the toy
puzzles that were
being done in the in the in the early
60s by AI people but what became clear
was that as we to use a chemical
metaphor as we titrated more and more
knowledge into the systems first about
alcohols then about sulfur bearing
compounds and so on then up to ring
structures the program became ever more
intelligent in the sense of solving
problems that only PhD level scientists
in the field could solve and so that
became I called it the knowledge is
power hypothesis but we we proved that
again and again and again in in dozens
of systems in our laboratory and
hundreds and thousands of systems out in
the real world that one had to build a
great deal of knowledge of the world
into these programs in order for them to
behave intelligently to twist a phrase
of Fred Brooks's he used it for some
other purpose but I'll use it in this
context there is no silver bullet you
have to know what you're talking about
and that's where the ten years of work
goes in that herb Simon once talked
about or that Malcolm Gladwell now talks
about 10,000 hours of sustained effort
in building up that knowledge in some
particular field so that was the great
aha that was the great what you might
call the scientific breakthrough of the
time when most of computer science was
focused on algorithms and AI in
particular was focused on problem
solving methods now so that was what do
so that was what you call the knowledge
principle knowledge principle yeah so
it's the idea that the amount of
knowledge about the domain of work that
matters it's not the reasoning yeah so
when we I'll go back and answer Arnold's
other question about the 1956 era but we
used to
have a we were going to have a big pad
to write on but we used to draw this
diagram of a of what we call the
knowledge based system which was a big
box that was called the knowledge base
and over here there was a big box called
the inference engine and the two would
talk to each other and the user would
watch this interaction and out of it
would drop solutions diagnosis in
medicine therapies engineering solutions
with explanations about about how the
program arrived at that conclusion well
the actual truth of the matter was that
the the Box the first box was absolutely
enormous and the second box was
absolutely tiny just big enough to fit
in Aristotle all you needed was
something like if you know a and a
implies B then you know B or modus
ponens a implies B be imply see implies
a imply see just a little bit of
backward chaining a little bit of
forward chaining was just about all you
needed mostly you need it all of that
knowledge so I've even and you may get
to this later on in the conversation I
even believe much further I believe that
box is even smaller than that maybe
Aristotle wouldn't even fit into it
let's get back to Ed's life story 1956
of 1955 1956 Christmas you've talked
about Simon and Newell but you haven't
talked about who they are or what
happened at Christmas what the supernova
was and why were you there anyway yeah
good questions
let me give you the eigen bounce story
and let me give you the gsi a story I
guess that anyone who's attending this
meeting knows what GSA is right no no
graduate school of industrial
administration on the Carnegie Mellon
campus in Pittsburgh which was almost
brand new at the time that Arnold and I
met each other 1952 I got to Carnegie
Mellon age 16 as an engineering student
I as a kid really was interested in
science and I didn't know anything about
engineering I had actually never heard
the word but astronomy mathematics etc
and saw an advertisement for
scholarships that were being offered at
he is a 22 technology those were the
Westinghouse scholarships I didn't win
one of those but I won an analogue of
one of those same same scholarship and
that was a that allowed me to get away
from home so I took that I I might have
ended up at MIT but I wasn't at the
Bronx High School of Science where they
knew there was an MIT so I ended up at
at Carnegie Tech and cruise through my
first year as an engineering student
with almost all A's and so my but I was
getting really bored with it and I was
looking for something that was broader
than engineering my thought was this
can't be the whole world there's got to
be more to the world than this and I
browse through the catalog I asked my
undergraduate advisor who
if you're old enough you know and
headshots and it shot said gee with with
your grades you can just take anything
you want so I found this course over in
a way on the other side of campus in
this unknown place called GSI a called
ideas and social change it was a
graduate level course and I was a 17
year old sophomore and I wandered over
there and guess who was teaching that
course that was Jim March now one of the
most famous people in political science
and sociology and education but Jim was
a brand new instructor and the first
thing he gave us to read was von Neumann
and Morgenstern sub theory of games and
wow that was that really was
mind-blowing that there was such a thing
so this went on and March got me a
summer internship at Carnegie working
with him doing some social science
experiments and in fact that was my my
first published paper was in the area of
social psychology on decision making in
small groups based on the work with
March that summer but March also did
another miraculous thing he introduced
me to a completely amazing person named
Herbert Simon and I have to break off a
moment and tell you a little bit about
the history of GSA as I gleaned it from
from the web actually from the from the
temper school history of the GSA GSI a
in those years which is the years i'm
talking about staffed with people very
smart people educated largely in the
social science disciplines liebe who
started the school was an economist
Simon a political scientist some person
later wrote in Fortune magazine that
Simon's higher
quote was a signal to the academic
community that a business school might
be an appropriate place in which to work
to work on profound if less immediately
relevant problems and then he mentioned
bill Cooper who was one of the founding
people of management science and
operations research March Hal 11 and
psychology Alan Newell a researcher at
the RAND Corporation who had come to
work with herb Simon on what later
became known as AI and in fact Newell
and Simon and John McCarthy and Marvin
Minsky are known as the founders of AI
Franco Modigliani and Mort Miller who
the in economics and finance both of
those people won the Nobel Prize of
course so dis herb Simon and then just
recently one of the students that were
was in this environment Ali Williamson
from at Berkeley he just won the Nobel
Prize recently so that's the kind of a
place it was and that's why I refer to
it from time to time as a supernova I
mean you might say that the Newland
Simon breakthrough was amazing but it
might have been just anova but when you
have four nobel prize winners coming out
of this one environment that's really
amazing Bach described gsi a this is the
founding head of gsi as a quote hardball
place unquote with quote no room for
second-rate work unquote where quote
everyone debated everything so that's
the environment in which this work was
taking place and I took a course from so
I went on doing my engineering degree
eventually got a bachelor's degree in
electrical engineering same time same
graduation that Arnold graduated
and but in in the fall of nineteen
fifty-five which was the the fall term
of my senior year I took a course from
herb Simon graduate level seminar six
people in it imagine that six people and
at that time Carnegie Tech was a not on
the quarter system it was on the
semester system so you came back after
the Christmas break and you did some
more work and then you took exams and
then then the second semester started in
early februari and herb came in the
first class after the new year and he
started out by saying over Christmas
Alan new land I invented a thinking
machine that's it it's an amazing thing
the cell to tell these six students
right like what could he possibly mean
by that there what do you mean by a
machine and how can a machine think and
what is he talking about and so what he
was talking about was a program called
the logic theory program the first
working AI program the first what's
called a heuristic search program it it
was incidentally programmed in the very
first list processing language IPO one
you all know about lists and lists came
much later this was McCarthy's work to
make list processing truly elegant
beautiful but the IPL's came before that
and then Newland Simon took this program
to the workshop that's regarded as the
founding workshop of AI the Dartmouth
conference in 1956 and they showed up
with a working program when I say a
working program it was actually running
on a machine called the johnny ack
at the RAND Corporation those of you who
want to see the johnny ack have a
world-class opportunity to do it because
it's 40 miles away on 101 shoreline
boulevard go to the computer history
museum you'll see one of the greatest
exhibits you'll ever see going on right
now and the johnny act is front and
center Derick and I pl2 was running on
the Johnny ack programmed by a great
programmer cliff Shaw and there was a
program that was proving theorems in
volume 2 of principia mathematica the
attempt by Whitehead and Russell to
formalize the basis of arithmetic and
therefore all of mathematics and it went
through chapter 2 proving all of these
theorems in fact in one case it it found
a I believe it was a two line proof or
maybe a three line proof for something
that took white hand and Russell two
pages to prove Simon wrote up that proof
and send it off to Bertrand Russell
Russell sent back a letter which you can
see online at the assignment archives at
Carnegie Mellon digital archives
Carnegie Mellon library Russell said in
his return letter that he's now fully
prepared to believe that a machine could
do anything so that was really the the
birth of a I one of the people attending
the conference at Dartmouth that summer
was Herbert gelernter from IBM herb
gelernter went back was so impressed
that he did a program to prove theorems
in plane geometry and at the end and he
actually used a version of fortran to do
that believe it or not at the end of the
year when he had the program running the
geometry theorem proving program took
the new york state Regents exam in
euclidean geometry the one that they
give to
high school students it was the only
taker of the exam that year that scored
a hundred percent so AI was really on
the road Jim slagle at MIT did the
machine that did various problems in
calculus and there were a variety of
other activities Newell and Simon's
famous program the general problem
solver and the chess program the basis
for her Simon's prediction in 1957 that
in 10 years a machine would defeat the
World Chess Champion now those of you
who think on a grand scale will not be
bothered by the fact that it didn't
happen in 10 years it happened in 40
years I mean 40 years is a miniscule
piece of dust right but it did happen
the 22 question when you call this the
period of no name for computers
number one and why it was all this
coming together a tiny Carnegie Tech
instead of some big powerhouse school
like MIT the i call it the period of no
name because no one knew exactly what to
call this this burgeoning increasing
level of scientific experimentation and
theoretical work in at in the 19 during
the last part of World War two and the
late 1940s though this kind of work was
called cybernetics which was really a
label for mathematical control theory
but it really didn't encompass the the
information processing advances that
were going on in the 50s so at let's say
the working paper series that Newell and
Simon put together was called a series
in information processing that was the
name of the papers the the Carnegie Tech
people when they when they got organized
to educate in this area around 19 I
guess around 1958 to make an educational
program they called it system and
communication sciences it wasn't until
nineteen sixty four that someone named
in computer science or computer sciences
that was I believe Purdue was the first
one and i believe Stanford was the
second one to use the name computer
science so I refer to that early period
that the Russians the Soviet people
always called it cybernetics they never
they never left that name
and this was happening at little
Carnegie Tech instead yeah well I was
why it was it to be fair well I can tell
you why it was happening at Carnegie
Tech but I can also tell you that MIT
was was as much of a powerhouse as as
Carnegie Tech the work online at MIT was
really really impressive in again you
have to go to the computer history
museum and see some of the exhibits
there too to appreciate the mi MIT work
and they also had an AI McCarthy and
Minsky as well but at Carnegie Tech it
was happening primarily because of three
people number one herb Simon he was
hired by Lee bak in the late 40s brought
in as a genius to think profound
thoughts and make everyone else think
profound thoughts secondly the person
that joined her from the RAND
Corporation where her met him when when
her was a consultant at it ran her was
doing some consulting and management
science at the RAND Corporation and met
Alan Newell and Alan dual was was
another genius up in the front row here
is Gordon Bell who co-authored a book
without Alan Newell is known as one of
the fathers of AI but he co-authored a
book with Gordon on computer
architectures I mean he was just a great
man and the third person was a person
that Simon found and convinced the
Carnegie management to hire and that was
a person named Alan Perlis and Alan
Perlis was simply amazing Alan Perlis
was the first winner of the ACM Turing
award Alan Perlis had a
compiler running on a 2,000 word IBM 650
nine months before fortran was released
to the world it was called IT internal
translator about IBM 650 you said that
was Ed's personal computer well after
Simon told us of what a thinking machine
was he we didn't have one at Carnegie so
he he gave us six people in the class he
gave us Xerox copies or whatever you
called him at the time photocopies or
something but anyway copies of the IBM
701 manual that was IBM's first century
into large-scale binary computation
actually a beautiful machine in terms of
its architecture and I took it home that
night and I read through it from cover
to cover took all night long and it was
for me a born-again experience I the
next morning I woke up or I left the
house as a what we would now call a
computer scientist and that was what I
was going to do so I applied for a job
at IBM in the summer and they had a the
first ever of their graduate student
programs in the summer I wasn't quite a
graduate student yet but I was going on
to be a graduate student working with
her Simon so they let me in and they
taught me how to program not only the
machine that Carnegie was about to get
which was the IBM 650 but also the 704
which was the successor to the 701 and
believe it or not I even learned how to
program a a wired program plug board IBM
card sorting machine type computer
tabulator guess it was called 16
registers how's that for memory
now I got long oh it was other than or
so I got back to Carnegie and the 650
was there and the only people who knew
had a program the 650 were out perlis
Joe Smith who was working on IT art
Evans who I guess was a student at the
time and a couple people in Gretna
graduate students in GSA myself and Fred
tom so that was it the the
mathematicians weren't interested in the
machine is that was a counting machine
it wasn't a mathematics machine and the
physicist couldn't care less the
engineers who staying away from it
because they thought that if they got
involved with this thing that somehow
Simon and perlis would get him to fix
the machine and so we hadn't all to
ourselves and so I would sit there at
the console for hours and just poked
away at the registers and the keys and
this big chain printer was next you know
clinkety-clinkety-clankety-bang- I have
my printer there and I have accept
things are a little smaller now and that
was a two thousand word drum so on that
drum was each word was ten digits so
it's 20,000 digits 20 so essentially
twenty thousand bytes and she I well I
don't have it with me but I have on my
keychain something the size of my
thumbnail which is four gigabytes so my
that personal computer was the one I did
my PhD thesis on which I can tell you
about if you ask it's a I'll ask you
were though you did your PhD theses a
pamphlet
talk about just with Simon you were
Simon student yeah so what was it like
to be a student of Simon I mean what was
his I don't know pedagogical method or
well what happened
I meant along the way to tell you
something that someone once said to me
about her Simon this was a fraternity
brother of Arnold's and myself named
Marie Talon fell Marie died a while back
but Marie happened to be a mba student
in he was a little bit older than us and
he there for a year or two ahead of us
that he went for his mba at gsi aid so
he got to know Simon that way and he
once told me that Ed anything that you
have ever thought of or ever will think
of Simon thought of before he was 13 and
that's really like it the way it was so
working with herb Simon was not really a
question of going in and taking a class
in getting lectures from from her it was
herbes view was that a PhD is a research
training apprenticeship and you treat it
like you treat a a normal master
apprentice relation you work together on
things and whatever you need to know you
get to know either because you have to
know it because it's part of the task
it's part of the the general milieu of
the knowledge you need to do this work
and what you need to know about the
methods by which you ask the right
questions prune the avenues in the
search space of all things you could
possibly do down to a few fruitful ones
that are have high payoff you learn that
by watching other people do it people
like herb Simon and al Newell and now
pro us people like that so that was
herbes view of pedagogy and there were
no required classes for the PhD in our
school when I came to Stanford I kind of
brought that attitude with me and for
years maybe even now there are no
require
our courses for the PhD at stanford it's
just that was the way so let me give you
an example i came back from IBM in
September of 1956 and I showed up at
herds office said ok now what no now I'm
here on a he get you got me a fellowship
and now I'm here what do we do and he
happened to have a issue of Scientific
American out in front of him there was a
a an article in there about the learning
of of what the psychologists call
nonsense syllables and there was some
phenomena that this guy named rock was
riding up and he said let's go after
that let's see if we can do an
information processing model that will
predict these results that was one of
many many articles that we were
absorbing and trying to frame a theory
that would be capable of predicting the
measured results in that psychological
area of elementary human learning so you
did your PhD thesis which you published
in nineteen sixty two call eep am the
psychological theory of learning and
memory implemented as a computer program
i would like to gallop forward and go to
63 you published the book computers and
thought with julian Feldman you stayed
at tech to work with simon until
nineteen sixty-five you called no I know
I I left carnegie i took my PhD exam on
one particular morning and night in
September of 1959 and flew to New York
and later that they left on the Queen
Elizabeth ship on my Fulbright to
England where I was for a year and then
I went to teach at Berkeley in nineteen
i postponed my assistant professorship
at the business school at Berkeley was
the only place I could get a job there
was no computer science departments
remember and the psychologists had not
yet bought into all this information
processing theory if you were in
Berkeley so I was working with herb
Simon what you might call long distance
now the nowadays it wouldn't seem
bizarre because you could just send you
know half a dozen emails a day and send
files back and forth we were sending
thick IBM printouts to each other across
the country then you moved from Berkeley
to Stanford on january first 1965 yes
and you called 1965 the year of the big
break was though in the
we go back to computers and thought that
was a Julian Feldman and I were were
also a student of herb Simons we both
got jobs at Berkeley we were teaching a
course in artificial intelligence but
there were no books on artificial
intelligence there were only journal are
in fact there were very few journal
articles there were mostly conference
proceedings papers and we collected we
we did photocopying of them for the
students but we realize we really had to
put them together into a
well-constructed collection and that
collection is a classic it's still being
sold now by MIT press called computers
and thought it has most of the sort of
historically classic papers in in the
field but in that in the I wrote the
introduction to computers and thought
and in the introduction I gave my
reasons for thinking that the study of
empirical induction would be the next
the next big next big job for for AI and
I was thinking for a long time that was
nineteen sixty-two that I wrote that and
I kept thinking and thinking and
thinking of what is the right task
environment in which to explore
empirical induction and eventually
dawned on me that just as I had learned
from her Simon that
if you wanted to do a I you might as
well do it by studying i that is there
were a several billion of these eyes
walking around on two feet and they all
did all the things that you wanted to do
in these a is so why don't you really
study them and understand how they were
doing it and when I asked that about
empirical induction I thought gee
there's a subset of these people whose
job it is to do empirical induction and
they are very analytic and they're very
they're thoughtful about what they do
and they're willing to tell you because
that's that's the way they live their
lives and that's scientists well about
that time I went to a Saturday morning
workshop that was held at the Center for
the Advanced Study of the behavioral
sciences now part of Sanford but it's on
the hill behind Stanford and there I met
Joshua Ledet Berg the Nobel
prize-winning geneticists but again
another one of these amazing geniuses
whose scope of knowledge and quest for
understanding everything covered the
world and later Berg was but he was
particularly interested in computers at
the time and and because of John
McCarthy is discussing it with it models
of thinking built on out of computer
language so that's why he was at this
Saturday workshop when I told him what
my interest was but that I really needed
a task to use a formal language I needed
a task environment in which to explore
this if you want informal language I
needed a real world playpen in which to
play with these ideas just the waist
Newell and Simon had used chest as a
real-world playpen or they had used
trick
metric identities I needed one for
empirical induction in science and later
birth said I have just the one for you
and he told me what he was working on he
was working on a in his lab a the design
of a planet probe which ended up being
the first Viking Lander that would
search for life-forms they were looking
for life on Mars but they weren't
expecting to find spiders crawling
around what they were expecting to find
at most was life precursor molecules and
so in order to identify those you would
send along an instrument called a mass
spectrometer which would help it's a
physical it's physical chemistry an
analytic chemistry and sorry physical
analytic chemistry that would identify
what the structure of those organic
molecules was all about and as part of
that he was in his laboratory doing the
mass spectrometry of amino acids and so
why didn't we just start with those the
induction problem was given an array of
data which came from the mass
spectrometer namely the frat Lee wait
the molecular weight of the fragments of
these molecules versus the relative
abundance of fragments that that way to
two-dimensional spectra then what's the
organic molecule what's the know the
Seas and the h's and the ends and the
O's how are they connected not in
three-dimensional space but in the least
topologically and therefore identify and
so that's what we started to do and we
he had already programmed a as
incidentally it was his exercise in
getting back into computing the after a
long period of time when he had nothing
to do with computers but he had already
programmed an algorithm which would be
was capable of generating the space of
all possible seas HSN
ohs given a certain number of each of
those however that's a very large space
for any significant molecule I mean
large in the sense that we think of
chess move spaces as being very large
these are very large spaces and the
question is how do you use the empirical
data from the mass spectrometer to prune
that to get to the right answer or if
you can't get exactly to the right
answer can you can you give the chemists
at least two or three or four best
answers the general view there being
that the chemist might know something
that he didn't tell you that you didn't
know that pick this one out rather than
that one so we didn't really give him
the best we gave him a little short list
of the best ones and that's the way we
perforate acknowledged into the system
we kept getting more and more and more
and more and more of this knowledge we
invented the the rule-based form of the
knowledge which has become the standard
way of representing knowledge not only
an expert systems but in business
systems in general recently I was I did
a search in Google on the the phrase
business rules got more than 100,000
hits on business rules and that was all
started there with the Denver project
representing mass spectrometry chemical
mass spectrometry in those fragmentation
rules became really the first so that
was the big herbs that was the big break
expert expert yeah let me just say that
for me that was a big breakthrough
because a break sr we break with the
past because remember the setting i had
come out of and had worked for five
years thereafter with herb Simon was
psychology we were trying to we were
doing an information processing model of
human verbal learning behavior and
seeing if we can publish papers about it
in the Journal of verbal learning
verbal behavior when I really look down
into myself I realized that the reason I
had gotten into this field wasn't that
at all I mean for her it was only that
he loved that that was he he was a
psychologist and indeed he won the
equivalent of the Turing award in
psychology and so did Alan Newell but I
was really interested in doing what a
statistician named IJ good that Gordon
will remember IJ good in the 50s talked
about the ultra intelligent computer
that was his terminology and really I
was out after the ultra intelligent
computer and eventually that became
expert systems but it was no accident
that that that I was pushing things in
the direction of expertise that's what I
was looking for the world's best at
something and you know it really
actually so this was the launchpad so
now what I'd like to do is to take a
gallery through the rest of the
seventies the 80s and the 90s during
that period you found that the
intelligences of laboratory at Stanford
you directed Stanford's computation
Center you chaired Stanford's computer
science department in addition to those
day jobs you wrote three books many
seminal papers you were the founding
editor of mcgraw-hill computer science
series and you founded three companies
you told me that you took a very
important lesson from this period oh I
that must be what I probably told Arnold
was this is I guess Nancy Reagan
summarized it in just say no but you
have that yet to learn how to say no and
if you don't know how to say no you get
but you all those things but you flunked
but I think of all of those things that
he just mentioned the the two that were
the least fun we're running the computer
center and run
the computer science department I think
if I had to do it all over again I
wouldn't have done those two things all
oh don canoes he's really at me for this
computer science thing because he says
ed you really were a good chairman you
shouldn't say that but the the business
about the books was a quite deliberate
strategy that was not accidental at all
that wasn't just saying oh I guess it's
time for me to write books that was a
deliberate strategy that came from the
successes of not only Dendra but several
other expert systems projects that were
working so well that it was almost
unbelievable like Ted shortleaf and
Bruce Buchanan's work on myson or the
work on that it deck that Gordon helped
push a deck on configuration systems and
other work at our laboratory penny knee
and I worked on a very difficult problem
that had to do with a secret problem
actually having to do with finding
Soviet submarines off the coast of the
continental shelf and so I just saw that
this field was going to have to be
populated by a large number of people
and we were only training a small number
of people and it was us and a handful at
MIT and a handful at Carnegie Mellon and
this was just not it the world had to
know about this so lots of student labor
lots of student research lots of editing
lots of careful organizing led to
actually it turned out to be four
volumes of the handbook of artificial
intelligence which turned out to be sort
of the best seller may I book for debt
for decades until the most recent text
books came out there was also the
question of letting the rest of the
world know about this so it happened
that the Japanese were doing they
decided that this work was important to
them and they launched a national
project called the Japanese fifth
generation project and so I in a writer
colleague friend of mine Pamela McCoy
doc who I knew way back from my Berkeley
days and she had written a wonderful
book called machines who think which
incidentally 25th the a special 25th
annual 25th anniversary edition came out
a few years ago if you want to go get
that book Tamela and I wrote a book
called the fifth generation and we I use
that as a platform for telling the story
of AI and expert systems and how the
research at DARPA led to it and how what
it means to do long-term work and have
big payoffs and so on so we have to fast
forward again to that great year in 1994
it was a good year for another reason
you change jobs he became chief
scientist of the United States Air Force
why and what does the chief scientist do
besides get free rides and f15 jet
fighters I've seen a picture of you in
flight suit and helmet and you have this
silly smile on your face like a kid in a
candy store oh you actually get to do
more than that I actually I actually was
the second man in a one in a one-seater
f-16 the second man of course is for the
training version of the f-16 we did
aerial combat over the deserts in
Arizona and and I actually flew a b-17
bomber for a while so you were there
from but anyway the 94 to 97 on one day
else what in 19th as soon as I got to
Stanford I met somebody who a professor
who became had been chief scientist to
the Air Force and he told me about the
job and what a great job it was and how
fun he had had in that and then after he
had gone from Caltech into that job and
then he came to Stanford and so I knew
about the job and one day the phone rang
and the on the other end was a person I
had never met but I was serving on a
committee that she was chairing Sheila
would know from MIT in the arrow
asteroid apartment and she described the
job of Air Force chief scientist and
asked if I knew anyone who would be a
good candidate for that job because she
was going to need somebody she didn't
wasn't able to actually tell me on the
phone at that time what was going on but
a few days later it was announced that
she was going to be Secretary of the Air
Force and since I knew all about the job
I said what you wanted to know if I was
interested in the job and it was in
Washington but take me away from
Stanford stuff and my family but I
talked to Penny about it overnight and
called her up the next day and said yeah
sounds great let's do it so she asked
for a three-year commitment and that's
why it was 94 through 97 what the chief
scientist of the Air Force does is well
number one the chief scientist works for
the chief of staff of the Air Force
who's a force are so if so facto if you
follow the rule based system which is
the air force or the Defense Department
if so facto you are a three-star general
so I had the the I had the equivalent
rank of three star general which I'll
tell you it's really good to be you know
outdoor windows on the e ring but what
you get to be is the the chief of
staff's window on science looking out at
all of science that might be of use to
the Air Force but in particular looking
at the laboratories that the Air Force
runs they run laboratories that cost
them several billion dollars a year they
run a whole basic research program
through a fos are that cost hundreds of
millions
a billion dollars a year plus the Air
Force needs a representative in the
science circles of Washington someone to
talk to the NSF people someone to talk
to the chief scientist of the Commerce
Department the Office of Science and
Technology Policy and so on and so on
plus the chief occasionally has a real
scientific problem that he wants answers
to like for example the scientific
advisory board a 60-member volunteer
board scientists advising the Air Force
was pushing him to start a project
called the airborne laser the airborne
laser was going to be up there it was
going to be a gigantic version of the
747 we now call it the 747 800 or
something like that it's a huge version
of it it was going to carry a chemical
laser and it was going to shoot the beam
through adaptive optics and 250 miles at
the end of that beam was going to be a
hole something about the size of a
quarter which will heat the side of a
scud missile as a scud missile was
rising remember that was a time that the
Iraqis were shooting scuds at the
Israelis right so you needed this
airborne laser like tomorrow well the
airborne laser is still not finished but
he needed advice on you know what's up
with this project he needed scientific
advice I was not a physicist so I
couldn't comment on the the chemistry of
that or the power of that laser but I
could comment on what kind of system
science would be needed and what kind of
software would be needed to to do that
and when I went to look at the
contractors in this particular case
Boeing and what they were doing the
answer was in the software area 0 as if
it didn't exist as if as if the problem
didn't exist they were going to solve
the chemical laser problem first and so
the chemical laser problem eventually
got solved with the software problem
didn't but anyway that was my job to
that's why Sheila would know wanted me
there to look
that the software issues that the air
force were was facing she knew that they
were important and chief scientists are
normally aerospace people or their
munitions people or their physicists no
one previously had been a computer
scientist they finally got the message
incidentally the current chief scientist
it's not only a computer scientist but
another AI guy mark Mayberry so when you
left the air force as a three-star
general you came back to Stanford and
you found that it was tough to go from
macro scale back to micro scale so so
here the attitude of your colleagues at
Stanford since Stanford is always
sending people to Washington to do big
deal things like dick Atkinson's for six
years was head of the National Science
Foundation eventually it was present at
the University of California but you
know condi rice goes off and she was
national science advisor in that
secretary of state and people are always
doing that and here comes back this
3-star general and they you know are you
back what are you teaching next quarter
Oh in introduction to AI oh yeah right
in track well I did that for a couple
years and then I said no I'm used to
playing on a bigger stage so but it was
about time to retire anyway so I retired
but you're still a professor emeritus
said yeah I'm about professor emeritus
so-called recalled to active duty though
weird closing in on the end of our
conversation time
I've been receiving your question from
the audience and most of them I think
can be covered in one big question which
i'd like to ask on behalf of the ones
that have come in from the audience and
there are a couple that we just don't
have time to cover from which I
apologize to the contributors the big
final question that most of these cover
is for a I looking forward what are the
big breakthroughs waiting to happen you
told me about three being breakthrough
areas the yeah that's so that's a very
good question from the people in the
audience who asked it and Arnold who
asked me about that a few weeks ago let
me answer it in two ways
number one the AI field is the sum total
of what the AI researchers are doing so
there's no word from on high as to what
the AI feel should be it it is what
people do and about 15 years 20 years
ago by now AI people started to down the
road of well you can approach
intelligence from the low levels upward
or from the high levels downward and
high levels i mean highly symbolic
extremely complex problem solving
typical example would be Newell and
simon almost from the beginning working
on chess-playing programs or my working
with a Nobel prize-winning geneticist
and a famous chemist on mass
spectrometry that sort of high level
stuff or you could work on it from the
bottom up like Raj ready when I got to
Stanford Raja was John McCarthy student
and he was working on speech
understanding trying to understand
speech waveforms that's very low level
and then working upward to higher levels
of contextual understanding of the of a
set of the sentence of the utterance so
high level reasoning work in AI as kind
of is not being done much anymore and if
you want to read a kind of an article
that talks about it this month's wired
magazine happens to have that as its
special cover story ai is here again but
it's not what you expected it to be so
but I'm going to answer Arnold's
question from the point of view of the
high level stuff what I would do if I
had another career in AI that was that's
about to happen which is which I don't
have one about half but
the issue is modeling the processes of
creativity what does it mean what is a
creative act and what does it mean to to
discover something that is creative so I
would work number one on that issue
because I think that issue is right for
working on right now and it's been
largely ignored even though there was an
excellent article on it the presidential
address that Bruce pecan and published
in the AI magazine a few years ago his
presidential address with triple-a I
presidency I'm going to talk about that
one a little more but I let me just
mention that see I told Arnold they were
three yeah creativity was one of them
i'm also the combinatorial creativity a
pattern recognition and knowledge
acquisition yeah ok the let me talk
about the knowledge acquisition one very
briefly if the diagram I described to
you earlier is correct that the big box
is the knowledge box you just have to
fill up the knowledge box if if you want
a program to know about everything you
have to have some way of getting that
knowledge in there and for most of us
the way except except for the common
sense knowledge of working around the
world of doing things in the world which
problem Doug Lennon has been working on
for 20 years now 30 years in Texas but
other than that if you want to do it in
any specialty field let's say say
chemistry you don't say why don't you
just go out and find out about chemistry
what you say is here's a book on
chemistry read this book and we don't
have any programs that read articles and
books
and learn knowledge of those domains
from that reading now that's another
problem that's really right for working
on we know enough about knowledge
representation we know enough about
semantic processing our natural language
understanding people are very very good
these days it's all right for coming
together and indeed the National Library
of Medicine has been sponsoring research
in this area and DARPA made it its
number one thrust a few years ago I
don't know where it stands right now but
they were actually sponsoring research
in that so that was a third of them the
second of them was pattern recognition
and that's too long a story to go into
other than saying that that's where I
want to squeeze Aristotle out of the box
I think that the way we my feeling now
is that the way we think is we have an
immense number of very simple one level
or two level rules in our head about
almost everything and we to use the
language of rule based systems we look
at the left hand side and do a match and
the right hand side tells us what we're
looking at and or what to do and that it
isn't that we reason about that we just
know about that because we've seen it
and that's what the 10,000 hours is all
about so take her here's the experiment
that herb Simon ran when when he became
interested in the problem of what his
expertise I think he was interest got
interested in it because of the work on
expert systems but you show a master a
master chess player and a novice chess
player boards that have action going on
but you give each of them only a
fraction of a second to look at the
board it's done with a machine called a
kiss to scope the master player sees and
to round the numbers too
two even numbers the master chess player
sees a hundred percent of all the action
what's important and the novice player
sees zero percent of all the action now
that's what the master has been doing
like Bobby Fischer from the time he was
six until he was 16 that's the his ten
years for learning all of that and when
you when you watch the football games as
I do every weekend and you hear the
announcer say that so-and-so just sees
the field and he sees it see its
unfolding in a way that he didn't expect
but he knew that guy was going to be
open whereas this this guy that's only
been in the league two years he he has
to think about it and he really didn't
quite see that guy being open well it
isn't that the guy who was there 15
years thought about it he has seen that
happen so many times in practice in
games that he just knows that
configuration means that guys open do
you summarize that by saying expertise
is pattern recognition yes thank you so
now I want to talk about creativity and
to talk about creativity I have to go
back to let me let me give you a little
story and then I'll give you two
examples beyond that story
chess is a bounded game 8 by a
chessboard 16 pieces on each side with
limited mobility and yet and yet the
number of possible routes from the
beginning of a chess game to a win-loss
or draw is 10 to the 120th power
inconceivably large number more than you
could soar in all the particles that
have spin in the universe I mean so
question is to find something good that
is a satisfactory solution to a problem
in that otherwise astronomically large
space herb Simon coined a term
satisficing to mean you're not looking
for the sharpest needle in the haystack
you're just looking for a needle sharp
enough to sew with now we humans have
very limited ability to look down into
this enormous space so if we're chess
players if we're not very good we do if
i go here and he goes there and i go
here and he goes there and we look at a
few hundred things if your master chess
player you know the patterns and you you
look at a few hundred things but but you
don't look at ten to the fiftieth things
or ten to the twentieth things there's a
kind of a cone of things you look at but
within that cone there might be some
there probably will be some avenues that
no one has ever gone down some avenues
of do this do that do this do that do
this with the known parts that no one
has ever gone down and when you go down
that even if you stop at a certain point
because you can't go from down a big
space you will be surprised with what
you see so let me
you the story of Garry Kasparov and the
interview he gave at the end of game
three of the match with deep blue the
IBM sponsored deep blue match where deep
blue beat Kasparov and in the third game
deep blue made an absolutely sensational
move from a chess players point of view
'breasttaking move and it completely
through Kasparov off because he thought
he knew how these programs worked in
fact had had studied the IBM program in
the year before playing it because he
had played at the year before and he had
beaten and when one of the journalists
asked him to describe the experience he
said and he's not a religious person he
but he used the metaphor he said it was
like looking into the mind of God by
which he meant it was a very
sophisticated path that no one in the
history of chess had ever looked at
before and yet it wasn't all that deep
it was just not uncovered before ok now
keep that in mind that's reminds me of
actually a joke of about looking down
into this cone reminds me of these
remember this oh I don't want to tell
the whole long joke but it's about these
two guys in the mountains who are hiking
and there they take their shoes off and
go wash themselves in the river and then
there's a bear and they have to run away
from the bear and one guy starts to run
away but the other guy sits down on a
rock and puts on his shoes and the other
guy yells at him what are you doing know
what you want to run away from that
berries that no my job is just to run
faster than you well the same thing with
this looking down into the cone of one
of these spaces to get better than
people you don't have to go too far you
just have to get further than any of you
can go
or than Kasparov can go or that the best
physicist can go or the best
mathematicians so two other stories one
will be visual there's a very very smart
guy was a young guy now is it God Linnet
I mentioned it before doing his thesis
and he did one of his thesis was not to
look for an elegant proof of a theorem
look for a theorem that was interesting
to prove a theorem that was interesting
to prove so he had to have he had to
have criteria of interestingness in
theorem hood theorem admiss and he did
that it's called am automated
mathematician and you know what are the
chances that PhD student can stumble on
anything that was new to mankind right
zero well one day Doug came across
something which the program declared was
very interesting and Doug had never seen
it before had never even heard of it
before he took that too now who and who
in the computer science department would
you go to if you had one of these things
you'd go to Don Knuth right he took at
the Don canoes Don had never seen it
before so it looked like for a moment
that it was new to mankind well it
actually wasn't it was first stumbled
upon by the great Indian mathematician
revolution and revolution had looked at
it proved a few things about it about
that kind of entity and then dropped it
and no one else had worked on it since
so although it wasn't totally new to
mankind it was really rare and that was
done in 19
ducks thesis was nineteen seventy six to
nineteen seventy-eight so we're not
talking about anything really modern
okay now to use his terminology
fast-forward nineteen nineteen
seventy-two from with a long story
behind it that it won't tell you I I
stumbled upon a artist now a very good
friend of mine and Gordon bells named
Harold Cohen who was a well-known young
British artist at the time but he had
moved to the University of California
San Diego to head there art department
and he was particularly known as a major
colorist Harold had stumbled on the
writings of Newell and Simon and
realized that gee you know if there if
those guys are making models of minds
like Bertrand Russell's mind or a chess
players mind what can I Harold Cohen
make a model of my own mind how what am
i doing what is in my head what's going
on there when I'm drawing things and so
he started to well he conceived of doing
it and then I met him and invited him to
come up to the Stanford artificial
intelligence lab and where we could give
in the computers and the techniques and
the list spent teaching and all that
need took it all back to San Diego two
years later and continued working on it
and he's still working on well his
system over the years one man system
he's writing all the programs just like
Michelangelo shipped all the marble off
the stone by himself didn't have anyone
helping him he ended up having a
rule-based system with thousands and
thousands and thousands of rules many
many many of which were rules about
coloring he started out his work without
the complications of color because
that's
complicated but under the influence of
myself penny Gordon and others he built
a painting robot that was first
exhibited at the computer museum in
Boston and one and Harold has had shows
all over the world but one day Harold
sent my wife penny and I a slide we
better bring it up here and this this is
Harold's gift but this was done by
Harold's program Aaron a huge expert
system and the longest live expert
system in the history of AI and what's
it so interesting about this is that
that when Harold and I and penny went
over pieces of this you can come up
later and see it but we went over pieces
of this thing like in here and in here
and in here the colorations are
amazingly interesting and Harold even
though he is a major colors he said that
he would not have the guts to have put
those colors together like that it was
that rule based system that didn't know
enough not to put those together now
what I'm asserting is that what Aaron
did here was a creative act and that the
move that because far off in Game three
of that championship was a creative move
and it's I'm interested in what's called
combinatorial creativity where it may
not be all of creativity but it's the
creativity of putting together new
things out of parts you already know
about but you can't conceive of how to
defeat the combinatorics to get a tan
Avenue which is totally wonderful and
interesting and novel and brilliant and
a surprise to mankind that's what I
would
those are the problems I would work on I
think that's a great note upon which to
conclude our conversation oh but you did
it buddy you didn't let me say what I
told the Pope would you like to say I
really have to finish this post okay
what you told the book he wouldn't let
me tell the Pope story at the beginning
guess why but guess why the Pope had us
all there when I say all of us actually
it's a few miscreants like me and all
the rest were Nobel Prize winners
literally but there is no Nobel Prize in
computer science and and the organizers
wanted to hear something about AI and so
I was there as well but the Pope called
this meeting in honor of the 350th
anniversary of the publication of
Galileo's a dialogue of the two great
world systems the book that eventually
got him into deep trouble with the
church and the question the Pope was
raising was is it time for the church to
back off and and decide that that
Galileo really was not heretical in
publishing this book on its 350th
anniversary I gave a talk on AI but I
finished the talk by some Arnold loves
us by spelling out what I thought were
the really great problems of mankind of
all us one is the the origins of the
universe and remember we're talking
about here I think this was like 1983
that 84 maybe when when this conference
was being held although Galileo the
350th birthday would have been 82 but I
think it was a little bit later than
that that we had this conference but
look what cosmology has done since since
then I mean we almost know the answer
now and then the second big question was
the nature of life how did life come
about and how does it develop
think of all that's gone on in molecular
biology since nineteen eighty two three
and four I mean we're closing in on
those answers very fast and the third
one is what is the nature of thought
what is intelligence why are we what
allows us to be here to understand those
things like the nature of the universe
what do we have up here that does that
and those are the really great problems
well the Pope I'm sure he loved but that
but what he really said was he's going
to set up a committee to study the
Galileo thing and it should report back
to him in seven years and actually more
than seven years has gone by so the
committee actually did report to it and
what it reported to him was they should
study it some more and make a decision
on the 400th anniversary of Galileo
publication of two great world systems
so and fill the boat to think about the
universe light and fog now that seems an
auspiciously high enough note upon which
the end this conversation thank you
you